squid squid space
Squarespace Squarespace
[Music]
Squarespace
squares sweat space helps you make a
website where do you want to or not so
you might as well use promo code
Hannibal to get 10% off your first
purchase because even if you don't want
to you're gonna have a website it's just
what it is it's the world we live in now
so go to squarespace.com use promo code
Hannibal for 10% off your first purchase
get a great sleek website increase your
web presence increase profits increase
your profile impress the ladies impress
the men impress your teacher impress
your mom impress your Paris impress your
little brother with your nice sleek
website and then you can link to it on
your Facebook page or other social
medias squarespace.com promo code
Hannibal
[Music]
speak
[Laughter]
[Music]
with Tony trim special guests Michi Hall
makes you how in the bill didn't or in
apartment sometime I don't like I'll see
a rapper at an outdoor concert we're in
the building no we're not in the
building we outside of justice [ __ ]
theater right now we know Park rappers
say anything again just get away with us
that's where I really want to start and
rapping to my whole life yeah
my love rap you could just say you can
say a lot of different stuff as long as
it's in the rhythm you cannot get it
going and we also got Brian Wildcat
Smith what's going on people how you
feel out there in the airwaves MA
well welcome you guys thanks for having
us brother no problem man no problem
good good to see you all how'd you cope
with the name Hanson Ramblers we was
high high talking and just came up and
it was kind of just a joke and kind of
tongue-in-cheek and then you know I hung
out with my man in Houston we hadn't
seen each other they've been several
months and I was telling I had a I had a
podcast and uh she's like what's the
name of it and I say handsome Rambler
and she laughed in my face
started making me laugh like what
happened to you we broke up she laughed
so hard it was one of the last well I
was laughing with her and then it hurt
my feelings when you don't laugh
if you still go let's not [ __ ] and I was
like all right enough I think we have
was that this Hannibal's idea is it I
thought it's a stupid name it's a really
cool name I'm gonna think it's obnoxious
to call yourself if you're just
averagely hats and you were just you
were kind of rhyming - like what rhymes
yes sounds ring yeah now I'm stuck with
it it's like you build up the height we
did when you see the podcast or like you
see the pictures you like ah yes hello
yeah I'm getting I'm getting handsomer
though I stopped I stopped drinking I
haven't drank in nine days oh no sign of
comedians and I've been - I still been
doing shows and going out I haven't been
says how holding myself away I've been
out in the bow that's a big deal because
I I'm drunk now a little bit yeah it was
crazy nine days I feel like an alien
it's so weird it's intense man without
clear thoughts and ideas it's my clear
thoughts you fill all of your emotions
and [ __ ]
it's very I'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
different but I'm enjoying how different
it is cuz just been drinking for so long
in that they have so much dump should
have it but it's so many layers to it
but you're around but you're around
drinking right so last night there's a
bit - do they do people piss you off you
know the first couple of days last week
when I was in New York I was really on
edge yeah I was on edge like a
[ __ ] I had no patience I was
snapping out and [ __ ] yeah my [ __ ] like
look man when I we without we it is the
worst oh yeah especially because you're
known to so people it's kind of mellowed
out and I and I like it now for what
it's a lot of it's a lot of different to
use a bunch of free time now
all of a sudden like what I got five
hours [ __ ]
I think I should read read have you
going to more movies I've seen Logan
I've seen get out I see I saw John wick
to see John Waite but Logan was kind of
disappointing to me yeah yeah I liked it
was very it was gory man
it was boring I guess it was gory in
realistic you know how they made a story
so real with the other stuff in a night
it's all right everybody it's all right
it is he's going in and my girls little
girls great actress no lines no lines
for the first half of the movie I'll get
her motivations across really good cuz
you know I kill you with eyes what I
said cuz I'm a bad actor so I call it
different types is lots of different
acting this there's talking actor let's
face acting when you don't you have
nothing to say and then as you know
object acting when people doing [ __ ] I'm
bad at bat faking background [ __ ] like
yeah I'm just over here no you know what
I'm gonna beg to differ man I saw you in
the movie or daddy's home classic but
that's the thing there's so many roles
that are like close to who you are yeah
and you could just kind of be yourself
in that character but it was it was
super dope man you never seen a movie
daddy's home man Will Ferrell and
Hannibal Bureau burst and what's the
other guy's name Wahlberg holiday comedy
man I'm tellin ya film that in the world
I was in New Orleans about a month and a
half two months filming that mmm so that
was a drunken time yeah
New Orleans is like saves [ __ ] like
he's like it's like the craziest place
yeah to be that it's funny too cuz at
when we were in New Orleans last like
for all the [ __ ] that's going on at
every corner does a guy with a megaphone
and saying like Jesus [ __ ]
yeah I'm sure so there's there's kind of
like for real when I went there first it
was weird you in a strip club and you
tipping the girl dinner to do dancing
right next to you you know because the
girls and the guys in the same strip
club this is real clever you were it was
Jimmy had bought you a Bourbon Street
that was on Bourbon Street I've been to
a handful of strip clubs man they have
you guys in because I cause I left with
the girl and that was a boyfriend was
the other stripper and I find out we
went up almost get into a fight because
he was mad that she's trying to go it
was crazy but not only that that's not
even a story that's crazy
all right story that's crazy is we met
some girls at the gas station and was
you know
so we've met some girls at the gas
station and she brought nine girls back
to the room and like I didn't do nothing
amazing she product one big no two bits
because i twin size it was bad luck it
sound like a good idea on paper but it's
back there is a such thing as too many
women that is exactly what happened so I
walk in the room and like we talking and
then the girls like okay let's kick it
off and they stop popping pills and
taking their clothes off who's like a I
left I literally left cuz I one of the
comments grabbed a girl took him over
the shoulder and walked out the room and
that terrified me yeah I said no we
don't do that not left oh man she bad
ground up let's go they were all started
had sex like at that moment so I just
left cuz it was too weird
what year was this this had to be like
2004 what is all you did comicview when
I do a common view down there yeah
that's like a week before Katrina oh it
was a week before yeah when we left we
were on the last plane out that like we
was on the last plane without biessing
around cuz I had some girl who was drunk
the sky was but people know like the
bags up at the banks and [ __ ] that's
when I saw that I change they did they
didn't know what what the thing was
people were used to it so we were scared
there's like tourists
uh yeah tours it ain't gonna be just as
hurricane we'd be alright so there was a
little parent for but nobody took him
serious like it was on a new
they were talking about it get out go
home people just like they they've born
and raised there yeah so they wasn't
thinking of a date you know how many
storms they've been through and they
left right but it was crazy yeah that
planes a golf and when I landed all that
stuff was on the news and I just I was
like wow I live you the last plane it
was me and smoking on the last plane
were you at all ever thinking like
alright I might just kick it here
through the heart really I was on the
last plane I missed my flight being
around was like if like were you ever
considering like yeah I was in a hotel
downtown I'm figuring what can happen in
a hotel downtown
you know nummies but the very place I
was that was the very place they got
floodable can imagine three levels of
water like who thinks of that I did yeah
you don't think about that like the
house is under underwater you it's just
unimaginable you don't I mean that's how
you bring the mood down oh yeah talking
about yeah yeah man good oh Jesus Mike
beachy and wild cat excited to have you
all on the show for the first time this
episode I don't know what episode is is
1415 is 1414 if it comes out Friday fine
tell like introduce yourselves to the
listener cuz that because you know
people just you know we're not doing
typical structured interview so now this
is you just came in just talking stuff
out of order can I do something cool I
can't because he was like yeah so many
yeah I wanna I don't have no but I'm do
this uh-huh it's Michi the man with the
plan understand get it that's all right
that's like you're ready okay yeah yeah
my ready so uh ladies let me know when
your labia needs to be licked that's
right no judgment in brainstorming thank
you no nice yeah yeah I'm the clip
clicker ready to tickle your snicker I
like that one you listening right
hey this is Hannibal Burres he wasn't in
a handsome Rambler how revelant so I
understand you and you leave you man -
handsome round the radio I'm just saying
this put you next to the speaker and I
will give you something for you Teta
titties that's alright you with me I
don't know what it's my persona yeah
it's always funny when I do I'll do
radio and then I'll be talking to the
elbe commercial break you just talk Who
am I having a conversation when you
switch the switch now I get up to the
other guy regular - yes is that I guess
that's been research where they said
this is what works this is what people
connect to you have to have clarity when
you're on the radio you have to talk
like this I guess so that's why I hate
it's gonna sound really bad but I hate
school for arts like some arts
definitely need to be taught the basics
but I think like even when it come to
film school they teach everybody to
shoot the same way and now you can look
at movies and you know the two-person
shot you know this you know that this is
kind of getting boring you know even
when it come to that kind of stuff with
the personality teaching you to be a
personality instead of you just being a
personality you know what I mean some
are just can't be taught you know like
with even with the peel with the direct
in the movies most directors got to go
to direct in school and this is that
another and that's why I think is
Harford on the poor good acting out of
people now because it's just too [ __ ]
fake that the starts you know the karate
fights it looked like absolutely not
like a real fight in the real fight it
ain't no kickers y'all just grab each
other and screaming for your life in
crime but that don't look good on camera
you know what see it though just a just
a sloppy fight a sloppy real fight I
think it was nice I hate sitting a fake
fight the fake
you can call it well here's the thing no
one dude is gonna be able to beat up 30
people ya doin under any circumstances
choreograph unless it's Cory yeah well
movie no one dude John wick I went to
saw John with two yesterday yeah he was
just kept on shooting people and it was
like a video game you can't do this
movie was close to I see two part two
but part one was close to real fighting
I think it wasn't as uh he wasn't as
amazing a fighter yeah you know this my
father was amazing cartoon in part so he
can't inspired me but you know there is
a funny thing about my animation [ __ ]
with John wick kill a hundred
[ __ ] I can get at least three
three months easily are those rocks you
sell it in front of my building
so I y'all go see John wick to solo I'll
go see it in Logan Square and it's cuz I
haven't been drinking one other thing I
just get crazy sugar cravings because
the liquor that's right in the city so
I'm gonna say and so it's the spot right
across from the theaters a little liquor
store not going that [ __ ] and I buy
just a demonic amount horrible [ __ ] i
buy some swedish fish I bought some
Reese's Cups
I bought some chips some hot chips and a
Frappuccino
they don't even mix we'll have none of
that no sneak that stuff that [ __ ] in my
code and I go in the movie theater let
me get in here with this [ __ ] and then I
go to buy my ticket give my ticket to
the person to go in a theater on a side
that the chips not honest [ __ ] I don't
want to be caught sneaking interested
yeah I hate all of that [ __ ] within the
first 15 minutes of the movie and in my
stomach wasn't [ __ ] up no munchies no
just snacks just snacks but that weird
combination of stuff I think if I was
drinking even the you know not drinking
right before but just in the most
greatly yeah I think it would gave me
bubble guts yeah but my stomach just
handed it like a champion I felt fine
after eating all that garbage they're
the sweetest fish and chips those two
together it didn't I was expecting I was
like this is stupid I'm gonna [ __ ] a
Frappuccino that's the [ __ ] top
machine a Frappuccino sweetest fish
species Cubs and hot ruffles and I'd
stayed in the whole movie as a two hour
movie that's a straight a hurricane in
the stomach man and it didn't do nothing
to me that's crazy oh man yeah that
woulda came out bad at least from you
two slid out of something that's not
like a drip slag carbonation but
ravaging on top of that I've had a type
of diarrhea were you like this diarrhea
is taking me away from my family
oh man I can't spend this much time with
my family because I'm on this toilet on
I can't sleep the stomach is the worst
when you don't know if it's a pool apart
yes got it got a really kind of really
usual booty feelings and your mind to
figure it out yeah this is really when
you wake up cuz you got a [ __ ] that's
the work because you're tired is [ __ ]
and then we won't do you wake up and
you're like I had a [ __ ] and that's why
you woke up that's worse way the other
words I use any reason to justify my
atheism and why I don't believe in God
and diarrhea is one of the main ones
like no but never let God would make us
do this if God loved us then why is it
why is he make us [ __ ] create this
hole I believe in God and I'm not gonna
say that because I don't want the mic to
blow up you think God cares about sound
equipment but you know I was in the
middle all is you but not like I didn't
believe it just religion and churches
and business just kind of once you
understand business is hard to sit in
the church and watch them just pull the
end profits you know so in just figuring
that out I just kind of walked away from
going to church but just recently when I
started saying okay man
right all right you saved me from
another vagina out here
I do believe yeah and everything started
changing up for me a little bit right
like it was a person who I remember the
day when I say okay all right I'm now
gonna be in the middle no mo i'ma
believe in God and I believe a
difference as and this is what I think
it's gonna be really weird okay people
are powerful our minds are powerful our
minds are very strong I think over the
years of creating and believing in
positive energy
it created a positive force and when you
doing positive stuff you're a part of
that energy so I don't necessarily
believe in that God God God but I do
believe in that there's a more powerful
positive energy that you got a you got a
cater to or you know we've got to choose
you can't be negative and expect
positive [ __ ] well I don't think not
believe in God just absolutely means I
don't think I don't equate it with
negativity yeah I agree
I think there's a different point of
view I think you just do good things and
not believe in God or you can have good
things happen for you thank God you know
I do
I've worked hard I worked really hard
and this happened I thank God for this
football game how about you thank you
offensive coordinator about him he
wasn't ran that play you know so that's
what I think that's it and so and and I
think you know my theories on diarrhea
and and be the freezing cold weather you
know they they help my position but do
you believe in like afterlife no I don't
believe in afterlife that just making me
wait so you believe in a God that no
afterlife no yeah like a are you like do
you have a real are you religious
yeah but it's hard to even believe in
the Bible cuz so much stuff and then
there's so many different religions on
the planet it's hard to say this
religion is writing that religion is
wrong that's why I just say positive
energy you know positive just attitude
yeah and then you kind of you know the
blessings come in it only reason I say
cuz my stuff to have in me is
unimaginable
like unimaginable like a whole comedy
club I'm pipe it's broke and I get a
whole comedy club after I just like man
I want to do a comedy club right next
day a phone call you know talk to us
about that well you got a yeah so uh I
opened up a comedy club on the west side
Chicago the names called joke hustlers
it's a banquet hall in must address it's
a 20 [ __ ] 59 46 West Chicago
is that it 59 46:59 46 West Chicago yep
Austin Chicago that's dope
yeah so my friend she owns a restaurant
on that two restaurants on that block
and whose restaurant she own the sweet
treats okay soy sweet treats it's a
popcorn shop all right and then she got
a breakfast cafe where the currency
exchange was on Chicago next to the bus
terminal next tacos yeah all right so
she bought that gutted it out and the
second floor is the banquet hall but
when she opened the banquet hall but she
just opened up I think a month or two
ago we already had talked about a comedy
club for a long time we've been talking
about a common club since I started
comedy it was yes so if I was saying you
know fell my friends ignore me whatever
but she was like no upstairs your comedy
club that's a that's great because
people is listening is not from Chicago
the Westside has very limited
entertainment really is really not like
if you live on the west side you don't
hang out on if you're really going to do
something is not anything to do although
it stuff is so it's not a lot of stuff
like that so that's dope there's been
Harper Mona because most people come
event from the south side because people
don't know West Side don't believe or
they like where is it
what what's that mean two blocks away
from my house whole area they don't know
[ __ ] about it won't come today owner
yeah yeah yeah but is this the vibe has
been amazing I've been very professional
we're having running the club I've been
doing my own market and promotions and
uh it's been fulfilling nice it's like
the same the good story same week I got
fired from lift mark Osman like we I got
the
the next morning I thought I thought
about it and meditated and how's the
next call I got like man what I'm gonna
do because I really don't have a solid
income what I'm in I'm sober and very
aware yeah I got fired first time they
put him on cots been like we they let me
back so when he let me back hey somebody
reported you didn't oh so do you have an
idea who it was
I dunno who it was I knew the two people
it was I first were a professional types
mmm No so it was dude it's kinda like we
eat on a Sunday and the father and his
son got in the back another daughter
yeah so it was it was a it was one of
them divorced fathers cuz I knew I'm
saying that to say when I picked him got
there to pick him up he was already on
the phone arguing loudly nice lens phone
or hung it up and got in the car and
then I was like hey how you doing trying
to be nice you know try to throw off the
weed there goes a manicotti like weed
job but I don't get to say cuz he was
like alright we're going here and I pick
up my [ __ ] daughter up and he was mad
already so it was an hour ride out to
pick his daughter and then his daughter
get in the car and she's really young
and an hour ride back and he said I
could play whatever music I want I ain't
trippin it's a long ride play what you
want so I play future know so I played a
chronic there and then when he get to Z
like you know could you cut that off
when I get his daughter in the car
another god you don't like black music
and [ __ ] you know it's a classic album I
was kind of associate so soon as I got
the musical I put on the white station
and black beetle zone and a little girl
kept singing it it was so funny getting
so mad cuz I knew I can add attention he
was so pissed he's like you know I don't
hear the no daughter the daughter is
like five six
[Applause]
I was rolling I was so happy but so when
he got the car in the meteor $80.00 and
I knew he would he would didn't want to
pay that so you could complain to them
and then cut your price down order just
wipe it away you know I mean so we got a
complaint like that so he snitched on
you to get a better price yeah yeah but
they still pay for that that's dirty I
don't know they shut when they shut the
app down yeah you can't see nothing so
when I when you fire means no yeah when
I fire you they shut the hole you can't
even get in there to check your money or
nothing you gotta wait for the email but
I think they paid me okay
I think they paid me cuz they say you'd
a summary at the end of the week yeah I
love the job though it was a great job
fires one on one practice and jokes
right oh my god and I was just I was
just material no I really liked so today
I got fired my reviews were like this
guy's great Bob I got really high
reviews that's nice
that's what he let me back but I was
just practicing my personnel you know
you could just really just engage in
conversation comfortable and get out of
them or make people laugh and I was my
golda every time I talk to somebody try
to you know make laughs because I wasn't
on open mics and then because I was
doing all the driving but I felt like
man every day talking to 15 20 new
people I I mean especially if a
[ __ ] is funny funny it's like
shut you know if somebody's funniest yes
yeah man I did so man what he was
driving me for my folks house on the
west side and we were going down Austin
the head to the to the highway we get to
Austin and Lake this is a bigger white
guy and he tried to make a joke and I
still because I was because he passed by
he he's like you you pass my charges
ticket he says you know you're in a bad
neighborhood when you see a Church's
Chicken right and then I was just like
not giving you nothing on that bro
a chicken am Batman but you never from
around here you can't make that Jews
it's a silent as right after day really
weird you can't get out the car so funny
I think I had like three awkward rides I
know one lady
you start out flirting and then it
turned into just got weird I don't know
what the hell I was having an argument
and she got in the car wondering why you
got fired yeah it blew over to our
conversation because I finish the
conversation with somebody else but she
agreed with the girl I was talking to
yeah so it was like well you should have
cut it off immediately I mean you just
had to be right there she was
uncomfortable as [ __ ] when she got the
cops you got the person looked back like
I made it out alive
so my vibe was just weird and then I
knew it got weird that sometimes I'm
seeing weird I just get more creepy yeah
on purpose just like for the experience
of it yeah just like hey alright that's
cool
I mean I always pick women up did you uh
did she tell you know uh I don't know I
know just as the creepiest rat I had
though I just remember that that creepy
vibe and then when Trump with the week
Trump won was the craziest vibe ever
yeah everybody and everybody was weird
everybody was either they got in the car
really emotional and or they got in a
car like really like like I wanted a
like it was crazy why do I do so honest
when they get in car by yourself you get
one why do by selfridge do i do oh I do
before Trump won he was gonna win just
because of the tone all the old white
dudes I'm I was picking on they was like
I never let a woman run this country yes
no woman can't be trust I'm trying to
yeah you think it was really like trying
to get the men together I hate you okay
I know you're black with your guys [ __ ]
these women oh yeah that was a total
with different white people older white
guys peeing everywhere anything like it
was you know you got the young guys are
kind of gay so it wasn't that time with
the old business white dudes I never let
a woman run this country never do you
gonna let me looked at his week and I
was like wow that's crazy
it's crazy and really sexist you know it
was a mr. job but you know you got fired
from how you got just skip over those
[Laughter]
yeah I got from them to me so what
happened what happened with them
whoa we got into it about the money they
gave me a deal well when you get a lease
program the car is like 150 a week right
so after I do and I was like the first
one with the lease program to in Chicago
from what they were telling me but uh
when I sign I sign a paper work or I
didn't sign a paper but is the deal
there a month two months of driving they
took all the money out from they gate
like they give you a bonus 200 hours a
week if you do a certain amount of rass
doing my brows do my eyes do my rice
kidneys big-ass checks and then like the
seventh a check they just took like
eight hundred dollars back and they said
their sister made a mistake Oh baby
charge yeah a black charts like a record
deal yeah so we got into it over that
and then I went to left and then you
know it was a couple bad emails back and
forth in they won't let me back damn
yeah these are the breaks but I liked it
though it was all good they they
definitely slave labor people cuz uh
that leasing program I was paying like
1,200 a month for a car yeah you know
but I'll [ __ ] my credit was bad and I
wanted to drive a new car
hey you got a husband you gotta hustle
hustler joke hustlers is the comedy club
joke hustlers at the comedy club
yep yeah 59 46 West Chicago that's
awesome Saturday nights man I said June
July we'd be renovating and knocking
walls down and it'll be official but
right now it's just the banquet hall
really nice seats brick wall
classy show pretty ladies come out you
know that's what I try to bring the
title bring the ladies in a place to put
these jokes in your face okay wipe them
off your towels so black women run black
comedy oh yeah yeah yeah definitely
black women run black you have to make
black women laugh you have to you know
I'm just not really getting that because
I would I really into men's rights and
it's said and a funny voice yeah it's a
lot of [ __ ] going in the world they
don't talk about what men go through at
all it is but you bring it up in front
of a bunch of women I want to add this
relationship show idea and I made up a
character who worked overtime and 40
hours a week to pay for braces and I say
hey this man should get his dick sucked
on payday and a women argued and false
Tim not against dick so he's not even a
real person he's made up he's fictional
yeah but they were so angry and that
kind of let me know that you better just
talk about women in a [ __ ] well yeah
well you can talk about just [ __ ] but
you got it you got to say something nice
first women y'all out here y'all doing
y'all [ __ ] y'all gotta get up you gotta
get that pander in you got a panda in
real quick and then you you you hit him
with what you want to say I got a edit
this part out no I'm not anyways tell me
about y'all history I'd know a little
bit but tell me anyways man
I was doing comedy when I met michi him
and little rail had already hooked up
they've been doing comedy for a minute
man and I got on I hit the stage we all
linked up this is what like mm this is
yeah mm mm one yeah yeah yes we all
linked up man and we meet you as the
host at riddles and DeRay was running at
so one shuttles comedy club business
Orland Park riddled comedy club 157th
and Harlow yeah
yeah so you kind of put us together gave
us a name you know last laugh troop we D
read name dear a came up with that name
yeah it was around Christmastime on the
way came up with it was a South gift he
was like hey I got a gift for y'all
yeah that was it last left yeah yeah
Merry Christmas put on first yeah we
found out when we saw the fly we was all
over the flyer yes yeah that's the
greatest nickname story I've ever heard
yeah yeah so when I was I started out
and I was the only new comic that was
the only new kana me and then I met rel
I forgot so I met real on the west side
at an open mic and I just didn't take
him home right because he lived with a
West Side and south suburbs like I'm not
taking you home today and he just stated
my career so then you met on the west
side and open my mmm and he has he full
right yeah I think this might have been
the state like the first time we met he
had it I don't know how happen why
couldn't it just like went home I don't
know come on
he was our URL so he wouldn't drop them
off on the way we went kick it and
that's what happened that's where we got
drunk and [ __ ] and I use like the best
mean you know how you meet somebody off
friends ever since I met we had a great
night when I just wasn't gonna take him
home
I just was being lazy and a so like I'm
not I lived on 175th field hostage and
he stayed away on Laramie and something
and I just was like I'm not doing it
today I'm just nothing going away like
my new best friend but still no we can
buy a pack of drugs and I was kind of
making a little changed in so I was kind
of like the cool come and meet you had
braids yeah when we met him he had
french braids first race yeah oh yeah
like crucial conflict Brady and I have
my name and my hair to embrace all so
this was this is a good time for you
good time to tell my life have a brand
new truck and [ __ ] t-shirts was still
being airbrushed at this point because I
had to be camera on juries remember the
big camera Jersey
if we win bread was out and we saw a
wildcat we said he's as part of our
group and it just we all just kind of
start hanging together yeah we just hung
together like it wasn't even know we
just learned together she was crazy yeah
all of Ixion's and burnt-out cars we
just stayed cool man they're gonna bring
up the crazy [ __ ] do things that I've
said they self you know the thing I mean
she lied to me when I started his game
because I didn't understand the
mechanics he said you know once you
really get to the certain point you get
five [ __ ] so once I start I have a
good shoulder felt like I was at that's
part well I had I could I could have
myself five different women you know and
soon I figured out it don't work just
like that you gotta get away a little
while it was good meeting that dude but
you know me cheese crazy man you gotta
you gotta feel you gotta feel to do
through the information and find out
what really applies to humans
cuz there's things that applies to michi
and then we talk about human so yeah if
I had my head right now it'd be fat
[ __ ] are here right now we all had
like porno names like his porno names
wild nuts well yeah this is just without
kicking it with with women you know Oh
wild nuts on the loose you know not like
we make conversation yeah on okay he was
wild nuts
little rail was the high school the high
school high school yeah yeah he fought
girls like in high school yeah were you
outside his room here several UK just
definitely that's like a high school
rhythm yeah students too consistent
yeah we was way too close in our
apartment really people came over just
with the cream we had a three bedroom
man
going down Harvey Illinois 604 to 600
people they just like on the couch you
just girls will just die don't know why
these girls loved us so much that I
career was the [ __ ] Scotsman yeah
like it was a man's man's career right
we didn't even go into kitchens like yes
you know me but it was they it was great
best time of my life yeah I think about
that so my spot in New York used to just
be terrible like bed on the mattress on
the floor no bed frame a room full of
clothes in system and are used to bring
girls back to knowing what the [ __ ] was
wrong with not you because this is your
house what is that I did the mattress on
the sad thing for a very I did that till
my 30s man yeah till my early 30s so
it's more comfortable for me for [ __ ]
like you can do more [ __ ] positions
with your mattress oh yeah because you
can put your feet on the ground the bed
frame is just strictly for decors not
even function what's the big deal about
having your bed a little bit higher that
it's you know I don't sleep on the floor
anymore I sleep I'm a structure puts me
a few inches above the floor well sleep
it on the floor and sleep on a mat on
the floor is a huge sleep it on the
floor that's just sad we talked about
the bed frames we did it was a different
time with bad friends was in veneto you
got to think about it though back
whenever it was 1800 1950s whatever they
finally had to get off the ground from
the rats a little bit Berman all the
vermin he was a natural part of the
house to come out Berman sounds like is
in the Bible Berman get the bed thing
and lift it off the ground about a
flitter so that way you can get a
comfortable sleep the vermin
don't stop out the vermin too hard we
might have to eat it later
don't you stop it too much you had a
case of scurvy you know I need to get
off this floor space is square space in
a trapezoid space in a circle space
triangle space parallelogram space
square space websites they do it all
right they have money to give me to talk
about it I'm in an orange room right now
go to squarespace.com use promo code
Hannibal to get 10% off your first
purchase make a great website with
Squarespace you want a website go to
squaws services addcom use promo call
gold squarespace.com use promo code
Hannibal for 10% off your first person
purses your first person
wait is this get out have you seen get
out anyway
Squarespace calm down no I have a
Chicago three units and I put them on
Airbnb they all know Airbnb to have
different looks
I'll stand one when I'm in town if if
isn't that booked fortunately it's been
they've been booked pretty heavily so it
hasn't been imagine that when I'm in
town so I have to stay with my parents
which is a funny thing to own something
and then still be crashing at your mama
house it shows how weird
cheap I am I'm in New York this is a
last Thursday it's about 1:30 New York
time and so I have property managers
deal with the day-to-day and all the
correspondence with the guests I don't I
really jump in unless it's something
that looks crazy or if a profile looks
fake or something
I'll say to them a let's not deal with
that or don't give them this deal
something but I really it's been twice
over dozens and dozens of reservations
that I've jumped and so these guys this
message and there's a party
there's a party upstairs these guys uh
it's loud I can't take this you just
sending all these messages kind of
panicky he's like if I had and and then
he says he lived he's standing in the
first floor unit he says if they he was
trying to go to his place and then it
was somebody on the steps like hold on
hold on do you know such a sounds like
blocking him hey they're not only
throwing a party in two places not
theirs they take it carry they take an
ownership over the building it's getting
kind of crazy so he's email and I'm like
I don't know what's about to do I think
the property managers over here I sleep
with something like [ __ ] I gotta get
this [ __ ] shut down yes so I hit up a
friend of mine I won't say his name
because he's probably listening
it's bigger white dude
pretty big intimidating-looking
especially if he makes a mean face and
yells he could he could do some damage
visually just his presence somewhere
he's a big very large guy if he you know
if you get into character he could scare
some people but he's like a teddy bear
type though like he can't I don't know
this I just know he did biggest person I
know and I hit him up first I hit up
Tony
but then Tony sent Tony said yeah I'm
folding
blankets what do you say I was with my
PJs on folding my laundry all you can
out Tony come to you he's very domestic
right now
never get my apron so I hit up this guy
and I say wait yet he tell me he had a
bar you know next neighborhood over I
say man is people throwing a party at
the place I need you to just go in there
just be a visual presence shut that [ __ ]
down so everybody get the [ __ ] out and
just just do it just be confident and
going you see I got you and then you
know send him the info he say he's on
his way he get there and uh I guess he's
in a stairwell this is the third floor
you and I guess he's in a stairwell he
says uh I'm I'm not going in there man
and what's up you see I saw a couple
people come out and they're going in
there and then that's where not really
this is text message that's when I
realized there was black kids up there
cause black kids he's like I'm
outnumbered man like it's a party what
do you think you knew you gonna be
outnumbered it's a party yeah
and so he's like I don't want to go in
I'm like dude just go in there and just
you a big white dude yeah black kids
hate big white dudes he's the police you
think they need a Poly's but he's just
he net first of all he shouldn't be in
the hallway texted me anyway that's
messing up your customer that's busy
looking back you supposed to be [ __ ]
lookin seven just straight open eyes
look and making direct eye contact with
everybody and looking them down and go
into the spot and stand you Texan with
me lookin all weird like somebody that
really wants to get in the party but
don't know if they cool enough anyways
bro so I'm trying to get him over his
scared nurse to go with I'm like bro
here's the door cuz it's a digital
digital lock something this is the [ __ ]
this is a lot cold just go in there my
face time with him and he's like I could
see it I hated that he don't he ain't
got it in him no more
he'll got a devil you say his property
so he he'll have the pad
that I have he doesn't like oh I just
wanted I didn't know right now and I'm
not gonna die over yeah it's basically
because he don't he doesn't have that
temperament though he's a very
non-confrontational guy so everybody
could turn it on at some point you gotta
turn it on people have levels and people
can rise to the occasion sometime not
take in that type of situation
you you kind of here's my thinking and
it's easy for me to say cuz I just see
the situation I wasn't dead yeah you
come into a party that type of situation
where younger [ __ ] it's a shut
it down if you come in with Authority
and say shut the [ __ ] down there's one
or two things don't happen either they
shut it down
everybody start getting out or they
ignore you and they just keep partying I
don't think there's a situation where
they just start beating the [ __ ] out of
you because what yeah sounds like you
think they just start beating the [ __ ]
out of somebody they're setting down the
part but if you say it's your crib if
you're like this is my crib not your
grave you have to lie to them and say
yeah young drunk and on pills is pretty
much the party scene so you never know
what a kick somebody off but finish the
story though cuz there's there's some
crime that happens in there too right no
let him let him tell okay it's church
party churchgoers birthday they told the
guys job nobody know y'all here y'all
can kind of leave they left kindly then
he came back saying he left they flip
phone booth flip speaker to the car when
the door open and 20 guys came in
beating the [ __ ] out of every guy yeah
that's just really happened and that was
just like a petty ass does it a hotel
and a hotel
yeah I'll just leave tiny yeah we
thought everything was cool we did
expect him to come in and beat the [ __ ]
out everybody but it was girls there
they couldn't get none of the girls they
were mad they wanted to fight so you
never know what in a party that's true a
stroke but I feel like out of his gear
nervous yeah I get that I don't know man
I would have went in there I would have
just yeah but it's different stakes for
you I know it's different states not
just win yeah I would like in front of
West
so we dealt with a debt yeah motivated
you like yeah out of it
so they say Joe and Pam hey listen Joe
I'm not a vice Lord but not one degree
away from vice Lord I know them I know a
couple fights well I don't know some of
them this I don't know it's been a long
time most of them get regular jobs now
you know what I know you and your
temperament you definitely would have
been like get the [ __ ] out if someone
down it would have just went down in
there and you might have gotten your ass
kicked by a bunch of teenagers that's
what I said listen we getting the story
is I was trying to I was in New York so
I'm trying to go how do you call the
police from New York there's a couple
more steps I was and you rage and I
already already raging man raises so I
see that he's like definitely not with
the shit's and not as on board with
shutting this down as I'm he's really
oh it's chill man some girls left it so
he's trying to calm you down and so I
just I'm facetiming with him and then he
just holding up the phone and I'm but
I'm thinking it's like in my mind that's
powerful because I'm in my place in
Brooklyn and I'm all out and probably
waking up my neighbors and I'm super
loud in Brooklyn but at a party over the
phone
everybody yeah I'm down to speak well
how many people were there at this point
I don't know you couldn't see like I
didn't even look that much I just saw
one time it's like something like do
bright you show up somebody to phone and
then the somebody at the party was like
oh I know due in an hour hunger
he's old yo do look familiar on that
[ __ ] up own baby I know dude
and then so uh he bounces and then so my
fault I didn't do any follow-up from
there cuz I maybe I assumed that him
coming through like that maybe I
shouldn't it so him coming to like that
would be enough to get the party sat
down blah blah property managers and
cleaners go through the next day they
like you don't want to know about this
these [ __ ] took the TV the TV I
thought that TV up there was mounting it
wasn't it was just on the table so I it
would have been more impressive if they
took a mounted TV yeah but uh they took
a TV they took two big-ass art pieces
hmm alright alright it's like the art
was a rude aren't like thousand dollar
yes good art it was good it was good art
that shouldn't have been in there it
shouldn't have been in there well I I
give them credit for at least
understanding the value in art you gotta
get in there like some way this like
some trap house with a nice piece of art
on the wall that's just oh I'm gonna
take that for the crane you know it cuz
they it was three nice as art pieces
from the same artists in there they took
two of them in eight and they left one
and you know what made me mad the one
they left was the third best piece the
artist is a Tyrell Tyrell Joe slang
Gizem Chicago Aras check out his stuff
online but yeah yeah I've got a couple
pieces from him and he wanted yeah
actually when I got him from him he was
like I rather you had these your spot
and your personal spot not here man
people take art but I this is my first
kind of venture like this so I really
think of people still in art yeah like
big ass pieces art and I said
cameras outside so b-but these
[ __ ] took the cura coffee
machine yeah they also took the knives
and the knife block cuz I guess you
can't just walk around with loose knives
you gotta take the knife block too huh
yeah in a trash the place was trashed
I'm glad I didn't get to have to see it
that's one thing is good about having
property man is and traveling a lot well
I did have to feel violated I didn't
have to walk in it and just see it in
his worst shape where's it gone right
away I just they send me pictures of
work but yeah that's it was uh I was
really upset Airbnb has been good and
they they responded to the claim and it
getting us the money back but he was
like damn I [ __ ] took the coffee
machine and art so how does that so
what's the next step
how do you what is like you're getting
the value of the art bag or the extra
what you pay for the value we shouldn't
talk about yeah I think though they go
they have insurance so they they covered
here's one thing I saw the reservation
when it came in and it should have been
a red flag because it was this fuzzy
picture it was a they catfished it
wasn't under this person it catfished as
a white lady from Iowa they had that
planned out anyway yeah get a fake
reservation and steal everything mm-hmm
that's pretty much something that's the
[ __ ] that's a crazy night go party
and usually partying is enough
I thought he artists but like that's the
thing when when homeboy went in there to
kick everyone out like the wudu you know
what he said specifically like this is
my spot or was he just like oh you guys
need to go because the way he was taught
the texted me in the hallway he was
probably coming in sounding like a
goddamn newspaper salesman hey you guys
got a need for he was real yeah he
wasn't going the other way because if
the owner came in there well here's the
thing man
well I got black friends but my killers
know like I know yeah we got no kill I
know at least and he may not have to
kill but you want that when you gotta
you got the vibe that's how you in the
party mood you got to how you going out
I don't know if that's yes from the
ground from but not a party up are you
stopping the party yeah we got a gun
Dean you about somebody happen to you
that's what do i do feel he was wise
yeah and I'm proud of these look these
for knowing art though you gotta be spec
but this was also a pride on this is
also a wicker park like not you know and
I'm saying like this it's not I don't
know
so one cat left his notebook there he
had his name in and everything ooh and
so I looked him up and I don't know if
he was the one who was a part of the
stuff mmm it was his birthday though
coming up yes he was
and so I searched him up find out
everything about him
I know way I know he work I know way
worked before
way he worked and I and I find him he
had Twitter countless I go to his
Twitter account he follows me on Twitter
a big following like did just start
follow me fan these some has awareness
of me to follow me right and so I hit
him up yeah I was a crazy night last
night huh and there's a happy birthday
man you left your notebook and then he
said I did leave my notebook somewhere
yeah and then uh and then he writes I
leave that I just kind of leave the
interaction in and then he says uh sorry
what happened to your place let me know
if I can help in any way [ __ ] no what
the [ __ ] like you were there any and so
I asked him a little bit more he says
the place was intact when he left he
left early I don't know what to do but
this
everybody's handling all the stuff on
the financial side but me as my own
being a sleuth and detective I really
want know what you are you excited
though that you found the clue you
followed up on it you found the guy then
you outsmarted them in the into telling
on himself
it was a genius plan he's not satisfied
because you haven't yes there this what
happens he cuz he says yeah I got to the
party yeah I found out I was he was at I
was at a studio Paris studio pairs of
nightclub in Chicago I was at Studio
Paris and and I got a text about the
party and I come through and then I left
at 11:30 and I was like wait a second
bro this is my timeline in my head so
you wear the nightclub and then got a
text about a house party and you get the
house party and then you dip from the
how you went to the nightclub in a house
party you get left by 11:30 it's a funky
timeline to me yeah it's a puzzle is a
possible timeline not for your birthday
any but it's a funky timeline so clever
get starts at 11:00 right doesn't matter
I know the manager at Studio Paris he
hit her up I said bout what time what
time his studio Paris popped last night
and she said she's like where were you
he won't even come to chance and them
came through at 11:30 it got popping
around in I'm like this cat says he left
from there and then got to my place at
11:00 or so it seems like no it was a
northwestern law open bar from 9/11 that
was the only thing this is funny time so
I haven't really followed up with him
because I don't even what do i do at
this point I just kind of gotta let it
rise to pieces the art the other [ __ ] a
TV a [ __ ] a coffee making [ __ ] some
knives ain't [ __ ] we getting all the
money back it's just I think my you know
the teenager in me is like [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
but the grown-up enemy is I move on dawg
you're getting your money back
yeah you're not getting none of that
[ __ ] back unless there's like some kind
of
the art is the main stickers are yeah
that's what a TV that's why I meant
plastic artists are this was about
respecting this space in this property
you want some blood and vengeance here's
also I don't you know I've been an air
B&B zijn people heard the stories on it
we throw it we throw some parties and
[ __ ] we try to clean up but we've left
we've left some messes how have you done
it yourself whose lesson we left some
messes messes a mess you clean up the
mess you might take up later no maybe an
extra hour to clean but I never took
anything out of nobody [ __ ] it never
even occurred to me like what if we walk
out this [ __ ] with the TV has never
crossed my mind that's a dope ass
picture I want it now that's never like
I'm gonna take these knives yeah yeah I
wonder how they divvied it up was it one
dude it took everything who was it like
do you hey girl you [ __ ] me in that
room so you get that heart that's how
you get the [ __ ] with Hannah former
thief myself uh you already have it on
your man you walk in there you already
looking at [ __ ] you already prices [ __ ]
out you know I mean don't be nervous
I'll used to steal I never stole from a
regular people I just different
businesses but being a thief you already
have it on you at the party the whole
night if you came up in here for the
first time what would you what would I
fake what was the first thing you you'd
want to take
now with the system in there that's what
I went there would give with the stereo
you're smart because that's where all
the expensive [ __ ] yeah that's why I
wouldn't waste my time here what I'm
gonna walk out with that [ __ ] yeah
that's a Harman Kardon is greatest
aerial really great for audio right here
pointing that stuff that right there oh
no would you take that or that or that
or that yeah good good he'll say what it
is good podcasting you guys so this is
why this is the red flag that I didn't
it didn't didn't go off too much that's
weird
the profiler that you it was just awful
picture of a white woman maybe 40s from
some town in Iowa and the reservation
you can do instant book on on Airbnb
which is where you could just book it
and you the person don't have to you
kneel if you have the verification on
your profile and whatever you could just
book it and you get the information will
see you information to get in the build
and all that and so it was the White
Wolf 45 or so 40 years coming from Iowa
booked at the night of or the day up it
was getting there around 10:00 and 11:00
on Tuesday the party happened Thursday
night what type of you know I mean I
think it's a fair stereotype to say that
white women in their 40s from Iowa don't
really live spur at a moment like that
yeah
I'm going to Chicago Oh girls night
Chicago air B&B maybe just pick the
place on a windy just pick a place on
the way there Wednesday on a Tuesday
yeah doesn't that middle-aged white lady
behave it's not I I have two questions
about that sure one it doesn't have to
be like a credit card connected to the
profile right yeah okay so or is it or
PayPal
so various payment methods so you're
able to trace that or was it stolen was
it identity that like that's the Airbnb
question I don't get their info they pay
okay Airbnb Airbnb pays you so are they
gonna put in some kind of an that's the
second question is are they gonna start
some kind of investigation or some
criminal activity because they stole
from your [ __ ] I don't know and did you
call the cops or like did you file a
police report that you check out broken
into and all that but it wasn't broken
into that well you know I mean access
closed yeah I mean like start like cuz
your [ __ ] was stolen yeah so I mean
isn't that criminal isn't that
considered theft well with the value of
the art is felony yeah i grand larceny
assumes yeah yeah yeah yeah the art okay
yeah right you said you wanted to say
that about it they were the two pieces
together were a few thousand a few
thousand worth that's what yeah
so what meet you were saying props of
those guys they saw that art is like
that artists percent of money they put
the hand on the wall you should check
something like that down I mean how many
pieces of this art did he make oh it's
very specific that [ __ ] pops up on eBay
yeah they hit the streets and we need to
stop set up surveillance for this young
man that you already got well I like
that kind of snow you know I think
there's little chips you can put on
stuff easy I mean you know who said it
Jadakiss mmm it takes something to
happen for [ __ ] to learn yeah you
gotta come and look dude the art look at
that ass
but yeah we were supposed to get cameras
out front a couple things it's just I
guess it's just cuz you know it's not a
hit it is good it's just like damn he's
my father's took the art off the one
he's bees is that big yeah did they
happen over with that [ __ ] no more
coordinated than that these guys seem
very professional yeah that's what I was
going to say that seems like that seems
like something that they planned out
yeah cuz I mean especially if they did
if it was like a stolen credit card or
some kind of a bogus if they were able
to some kind of like fraud their way
into their profile and then do it I feel
like that I agree with me to feel like
that was like a planned out heist these
look here's a think they got the create
through the party charged for the
particle is promoting at the club
nobody is giving up whether I guess
somebody got a text there's somebody at
the club in charge then yeah they saw
those art they took the art yeah they
probably had sex slaves in there like
the laid out at night the kids Jesus man
yeah yeah they straight up yeah they
sprayed a maid you [ __ ] you man hey [ __ ]
you
[Laughter]
somebody else's podcast no this party
because way too much crap it's just they
gotta get it what I can you know I mean
that's because the podcast we haven't
released this one but in LA remember we
were talking about we were talking about
how that little that little uh Donkey
Kong poster guys stop this is the
obvious progression from that and we
were tripping about that we're talking
about that but like well we had this
thing I had this thing this it was a is
Mario matte so Donkey Kong like Mario
match but in maps of Chicago
neighborhood saw a subway station I got
him in each unit I'm kind of telling all
my units now and [ __ ] I'm a detective
[ __ ] off Airbnb or switch up the art
anyways so somebody took one of those
it's like a print it was 80 bucks but
then I couldn't track down sit so the
guest that it was missing after I'm
her like what happens it is she's like
oh we didn't
maybe it fell behind the counter what
are you talking about the nonsense um
sarcastic ass [ __ ] kind of insinuating
that she took it and then she got really
offended but then I mean who took it
then did the property manager take it
that would be a weird move did the
cleaning lady take it did a guest take
it a guest of hers is just this weird
mystery well I kind of let it go because
if [ __ ] was only 80 bucks and it wasn't
a big part of the place you know what I
mean they know what yeah it just didn't
look of that like meat you you wouldn't
look at that and be like that's
something this steel I think that was
the first wave of criminals and it was
casing you to see what your response was
so they took bets and then a waiting
room is fine they witnessed man that is
a viable that is invaluable they didn't
have access then usually let me go break
some legs they say
Hannibal Burres and they throw the bed
down oh no no you can't say no it
Hannibal I think HP say ramble on oh we
gotta beat him up a dude you gotta get
out the cops they had some ramp Allah
says below testable of [ __ ] again is
that your mother do you open car doors
you that's right I think Michi is the
most vulgar you looking for they know so
habit yes I respect them little
[ __ ] man like this ain't uh
this is just theft so nobody really
gonna give up nobody on a theft you know
what I'm a high street cold goes nobody
gonna be like yeah he took it nobody
there's no who cares I say a lot when
you start batting and hammering people's
feets and ankles
my movies or street code see man I can't
I can't be involved and I do voices and
kids movies man
you can't get caught doing Indian burns
and can't be doing I can you know boys a
dog and secret life of pets men trying
to do a sequel da I'm trying to be in a
secret you need the person next to the
person that we're going to happen you
could have him hit in jail you know what
this is me you know it's good talking
about this with y'all and this is me
finding peace with it you know stuff is
stuff yeah things are things do you
forgive them the handsome Rambler
forgives you how's your Jesus moments
totally give you you know but you know
I'm really okay with it when I start
talking in the third person with my
podcast name I'm totally handling it
really well that's that sober Hannibal
talking right now
yeah the cannibal yeah yeah flippin [ __ ]
over I mean no I was angry something
like this is maybe I'd only been I guess
that was third day so I was irritable -
oh yeah yeah I was your habit withdrawal
yeah I was that withdrawal but I was
just really just in a weird mood man
that [ __ ] was happening yeah uh it was
uh it was definitely upsetting but just
a thing where is is I you got a just got
a row with that [ __ ] you go fugato
you got to find you know I got it i'ma
have I mean I have some security on the
ground that's within a few minutes drive
and available like now that now I'll
have that and I'll get cameras and and
put trackers on the stuff than these
trackers and handle it so that's it it's
a new business for me there's only been
a few months
yeah you definitely got to have cameras
on deck back porch front porch you gotta
have cameras on day like the [ __ ] that
you could tap into it your phone and
your yeah yeah
I want to give these people culture and
nice places lead well no I mean you
decorate a place I don't want it to just
be even uh even a [ __ ] Hampton Inn
room got something on the walls
I know it's just but I it was just I
think it was just me and being excited
about my first property and kind of even
though I wasn't living in it treating it
like it was my own lady it's mine but
treat me like I lived there where you
know which is fine to have that level of
stuff in there but you got address price
point that it was at didn't really yeah
present the value of the stuff in there
by man that likes type of stuff in there
you know then I probably should have to
place me at you know whatever 200 a
night and then you get a certain type of
client sailing that step yeah yeah you
got address it more like a cot like a
college a college place not a full adult
place you know what I'm saying like IKEA
stuff and stuff like that whoopsie my
stuff in there the art was the art I was
planning on moving it out anyway [ __ ]
happens man yeah [ __ ] happens
I would be alright my digestive system
is a point right now nice everything
everything is good and here in where's
Chicago yeah yeah times good times a
good chance helped out Chicago Public
Schools y'all saw that yeah
our programs are programs yeah and he
dropped Ted on that in school that he
announced it at on top of that and then
they're like what donating ten more for
every hundred thousand or something more
for every every hundred thousand yeah
that's a huge deal every hundred
thousand raised every time they raise
they donate ten to a solo school which
is great I I threw in a donation yeah
what's it their own I don't want to talk
about
you know you know I moved I helped out
yeah yeah it's good you doing some stuff
in Chicago Public Schools Walker yeah
yeah I'm teaching an improv comedy class
we're teaching it I work with the
company called a parent University and
they're trying to revitalize the arts
they teach mechanical engineering you
know they teach public speaking you know
a bunch of different elements that have
been lost and they got me doing a comedy
improv class
nice yeah yeah it's dope miss dope but
I'm I'm taking it to a whole nother
level like I got your parents going on
ancestry.com all that research yeah
research people in their past they would
find somebody in their past that they
gravitate to teach them about script
writing and acting and they're like
recreate a moment as your uncle was a
janitor or a comedian or whatever it was
[Music]
not yet I'm working on that that's the
first step yeah okay I think that'll be
fun for everybody do it cuz there's a
guy I'm on channel 11 it does a lot of
the different stars and they take it all
the way back so I think we all should do
that yeah just so you know I hate the
conversation now I have a people where
are you from like Chicago well your
parents from Mississippi where their
parents from Mississippi what about them
like what are you saying where are you
really from stolen Africa yeah right is
my guest out but I should look back just
so I could write 70% Sudanese 20%
Nigerian right 10 percent every time I
think about that I'll think about
somebody raped my grandma way back then
when they'd be like are you 12 that's
all I'm thinking about the slavery so
that's why I want to know well maybe it
knows not always had to be raped there
was a lot of interracial consensual sex
yeah for Asian everybody's got Genghis
Khan and they blood that's like real
talk everything
he was confident in yeah they would
literally rape everybody in the village
Jesus so his blood is in every asian
asian lineage is [ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
rape people is one thing but to be a
greedy raper yes that's the whole nother
thing they want to get you pregnant you
trying to rape they try to race out
everybody of the race yeah yeah when you
when you put it in a perspective like
that I guess getting my two art pieces
[Laughter]
apart man we gonna rape it I that's cool
did you do it now with the schools cuz I
have a loose I did and I've been looking
at some spaces on the west side I want
to try to start this Art Center mmm cuz
the west side for what I do I mean I
might have to do some more research the
West every little as far as after-school
programs or just things like things like
that where it's improv class or writing
class work or somewhere for kids to
learn how to code or you know just
different things it's a space I've been
looking at so cuz you know you get to
find a right space proper the West sighs
really really cheap it's fine especially
you go by Austin and essentially you can
get a big building foot and so I've been
you know I want to try to just get
something going just to have cuz I don't
remember having even those options I hat
after school stuff in high school where
you know play sports or do things but as
far as it's being a kid like I want to
go to this and right Steinman's didn't
have any kind of art programs really
maybe but nothing no I mean Stein is
getting really good now yeah school is
really just say they have way more AP
classes they got a
IB program International Baccalaureate
or something yeah there's a top school
where they had a bunch
kids they have scholarships and stuff
yeah well I want to try to yeah build
something like that
yeah the art scene yeah you should do
that man there's a lot of class clowns
out there man and people that are just
doing stuff they can really capitalize
like I'd started in high school doing a
speech team yeah like it was like oh lot
of kids didn't even know they had a damn
speech team but we do like original
comedy which is like stand-up yeah we
would do humorous do it act in a special
occasion speak in humorous interp you
know dramatic interp and that that gave
me options I didn't even know I had yeah
yeah I did debate in and that was my
first kind of do you know that was my
first it's taking a stand up well net it
wasn't straight stand up obviously but
they will start something that kind of
inform my approach now which is just you
know being really argumentative about
things that don't matter that much
and yeah debate that because it was
debate you you present your case and we
the the resolution that year was to how
to increase academic achievement so they
had different things you were argue for
tracking was one of them it was just
different ways that start to school
early a start school later that's what
that's one our cases so you present your
case you have the cross-examination with
the other team ask you stuff about your
case and find your flaws and yeah they
try to find flaws is so they were hit me
with something and I'll hit them back
with some quick and funny and then the
judges would laugh and [ __ ] and that's
kind of now how hecklers would heckle to
say something you like go back to that
like having known real quick yeah to say
well yeah it needs to be more most stuff
on them cuz kit yeah when kids are like
at that that age like right before like
preteen they're so impressionable like
one little one person one book one piece
of art can really you know like throw
them in a certain direction yeah so
that's definitely I agree with that
because this guy might just this kid
just might come in off the street be
like oh [ __ ] mess around with a computer
program like
is what I'm gonna do for the rest of my
life you must gotta give him that
opportunity you know I was at school
teach for about five years since I was
doing comedy you incredible life all the
time right that's why it's no pressure
for me to be famous in our rich not
because I really live a really good
lifestyle but it was a program I was
working for a car open book where we
read a book with the kids and then with
the kids together we acted out and wrote
a play and they competed like five six
schools we complete who had the best
play out of all the schools on the book
and it was great for all the things
you're talking about because I remember
one kid would be shy and then I'll make
them a star to play and then by the end
of the whole year of us doing four or
five different plays this is the loudest
kid in the room or they can't wait to
act out or they forget about the
audience being out there but it was it
was something that I immediately saw the
impact just from interacting with kids
and all that it was it was really great
and they just lost funding it's called
open book they still do it though but I
had like 16 schools I was a writing
coordinator and I would make sure the
plays and everything is that program
still going um is a funked it is they
don't have as many schools as they had
cuz like I said I had 16 and I think it
might be like three in that area where
they had though it's a it's on 35th and
King Drive and the good thing about
ramen man he came to the program to talk
to the kids yeah and he put all the
teachers out asked the kids how can they
help is a program effective and all that
and then he cut it but y'all really like
this Oh y'all enjoy this well it's gone
I want you to look me in my eyes when I
kill you we were effective or not
effective this is not something you can
measure you can't measure really reading
levels like from his after-school
program so that's kind of one of the
things this open book open book how
about this I'm gonna donate to open book
what it was still open I want to fix
right I want a sense like a busted
PayPal account
in Miami [ __ ] bounce back I'm gonna
check on open-book this great guy man
and I also got these uh I got this guy
who's trying to sell weed again well he
tried to get a pound to give to the
inner city to feed his players written
this card oh great a meat see you want
to plug the clothes joke hustlers yeah
the club's called joke hustlers it's
Chicago
Austin it's right over but oi sweet
treat restaurant it's a 59 46 West
Chicago website joke hustle to jail okay
eh you STL er it'll be up Friday Friday
the juggler at Instagram
yep joke hustler Instagram J okay e8u
SDLC are cool Wow
yes right well care you can check me out
wild cat comedy D a wild cat also social
media look out for the wild cat
experience acting improv coming to a
school near you
thanks a lot catch us we'll be at South
by Southwest doing the live podcast and
Esther's follies Thursday March 16 6
p.m. to 7:15 p.m. we have a show there
March 15th also I don't know what that
said but check out you know Instagram
and Twitter Tony trim and Twitter
Instagram Hannibal Buress and uh look
out we'll be in Austin next week
you
[Music]